london's latest attraction is almost
five meters tall and takes pride of
place here on trafalgar square
these visitors came from germany
especially for the unveiling
i love the matte color and when the
sun's out it really shines
the way the color glows is amazing it
looks great on trafalgar square
sphere
the square has traditionally been
dominated by nelson's column a tribute
to the british admiral who defeated
napoleon's fleet at the battle of
trafalgar in 1805.
the three other plints lining the square
likewise honor kings and generals the
blue cockrell is a lighthearted
challenge to the male grandeur around us
its creator is german artist katarina
fritsch
my main aim was for it to look good here
i wanted a sculpture that would be
interesting from all sides and would
work well with the historical
architecture which i love
but it wasn't meant to look
old-fashioned
katarina fritch is a major figure on the
german and global art scenes
she's known for her life-sized and
super-sized sculptures of people and
animals her trademark use of bold colors
lends her works an unreal dimension
it took the 57 year old two and a half
years to complete her latest work
it was a complicated it was really
complicated to create and make sure that
the chest wasn't too prominent it was
quite tough incorporating both the
cockerel's strut and its fragile aspects
this is the ninth work of contemporary
art to grace the fourth plinth on
trafalgar square previous exhibits
include mark wallinger's life-sized
figure of christ
a colored glass model hotel by german
artist thomas shutter and a very public
installation in 2009 by anthony gormley
where everyday londoners made their own
statements on the plinth
the plinth has also hosted a giant ship
in a bottle
and a bronze sculpture of a boy on a
rocking horse
now katarina fritch's cockrell has taken
up the perch
we as the fourth point commissioning
group ask artists to respond to their
location to think about the social the
cultural the political resonances of
this historic square in the center of
london tatarina fritz responded with
something that's simple that's elegant
that has a sense of humor and a real
beauty to it i think this will be a
piece of work that london will love
every work to feature on the fourth
plinth has sparked controversy and the
rooster is no exception
some see the cockerel a symbol of france
right next to nelson's column as a
provocation
but most agree it's definitely
eye-catching
i like it very much yes
it's
something new and modern
the blue color is great and a nice
contrast to this historic square
plus it's a very good representation of
a cockerel and it's nice and bright
and looks very good up there but i'm not
sure it's what i would want there as a
person as a permanent
position on the plinth
but for the next 18 months at least the
big bird will rule the roost here at
trafalgar square